on
uh
on the quarterback depth chart
if andy dalton the presumed starter
should get injured where does it go from
there here's maggie from last week
i'll give you updates as we go as to how
the guys are doing but as far as the
depth chart goes this is where we're at
with andy as the one
with with justin as the two with nick as
a three but all three of those guys know
that you need to produce you need to
play well you need to compete you need
to be the best quarterback you can be
and then it's going to be really pretty
easy for us to be able to see who that
is and how that goes and then there'll
be a process and a plan
we're going to stick to that it's not
going to change tomorrow that plan is
not going to change tomorrow the plan is
not going to change in training camp the
plan is a is a is a plan and it's been
thought out
and so as we go um i'm just taking some
time on this question because i think
you know this could go every day
and i just want you to know that that
that's kind of as we go here where i'm
at you know and so um
depth chart wise yep but to go back to
your original question hub
if that was the case yes then um
uh justin would be our starter
you know here's what's amazing to me
we'll work our way up the depth chart
from the bottom nick foles the super
bowl 52 mvp starter in jacksonville two
years later week one right broke a bone
while throwing a touchdown pass no it's
not like spontaneously broke he was
slammed down to the ground right and it
never worked out in jacksonville for him
it was gardner minshew after that and
then he ends up in chicago last year and
at one point fairly early in the season
when the bears were 3-0 i think
that was when against atlanta mitchell
trubisky got benched and nick foles came
in and he had the job until he injured
his rear end on a monday night against
the vikings i believe and then he was
just kind of gone after that he's
got a four million dollar fully
guaranteed salary this year he's got a
million dollars of his 4 million next
year that's guaranteed i think the bears
would love to trade him
i mean he is mired at the bottom of the
depth chart it's it's stunning to think
that the guy who was the super bowl 52
mvp is just a forgotten man in chicago
where do you think he's going to end up
there there's chatter about the jets and
they don't have a veteran behind zach
wilson there's been talk maybe he ends
up back in philadelphia i don't know
that that's good for anybody at this
point but where do you think he ends up
well i think it makes sense to look at a
team like like the jets would make a lot
of sense for me like
nick foles
starting has gone by the wayside i mean
that's the one thing i think that's why
the bears have made it pretty plain that
hey he's number three we know what he is
we know what he's done here he gives no
the fans no excitement you know i don't
think there's any chatter about him in
the locker room like oh nick foles so he
doesn't bring any juice to the football
team he kind of is what he is at this
point which is a really awesome backup
quarterback but i think like you know i
think it is that type of scenario with
nick foles where
yeah maybe a younger quarterback or
again a team that might be
in the super bowl window and feel like
hey again we don't want to lose a
quarterback and then have a backup
that's not worthy and we just totally
fall apart so that's to me the teams
that are going to be interested in you
know as far as which ones specifically
those are
you know you look at the the list right
here right now i mean
i i i guess you know out of the playoff
teams there's not ones that jump out to
me a whole lot mike there really isn't
you know the tennessee titans maybe
that'd be a conversation you'd think of
that'd be the type of scenario again
that i'm talking about good team
tannehill goes down you don't want the
team to fall apart but something along
that line and mike i'm with you i would
think that they're they're hoping that
maybe there's an injury or something
that goes down in training camp to where
they could be the backup pete's saying
bucks but i think they're all about stop
stop at the bucks yeah the only stop
about the only good thing about nick
falls playing for the buccaneers would
be that maybe tom brady would finally
shake his hand
i think that's the only good thing that
would come of that it's not happening so
um i
i remember now i had a flashback to two
weeks ago after julio jones was traded
to the titans and indeed it only was two
weeks ago it feels a lot longer than
that that we said they're going to need
a better backup yeah
now you have aj brown and julio jones if
if ryan tannehill gets injured and he
has a history of being injured and i'm
not trying directly or indirectly to put
the jinx on ryan tannehill by pointing
out the obvious that quarterbacks
sometimes get injured you need to have a
better number too and maybe that's a
spot for nick foles if they can make it
work from a salary cap standpoint and
maybe it may be that the bears have to
eat some of the salary to facilitate the
trade nobody's going to want to pay him
four million dollars to be a backup or
maybe they will i don't know they may
just have to do a conditional seventh
round pick if they trade him the other
spot's indianapolis
which
has
entertainment value for different well
that's why reunite makes sense and be
behind carson right but that's why you
can't say it as long as he's clearly the
backup as long as he's clearly the
backup it's fine there's no way there's
no way
i don't think so i just don't think
chris ballot or frank reich will buy
into that they're not going to want to
bring up you know ghosts of christmas
pass or super bowl passed or whatever
like that and that was a good outcome it
was a good hour it was good but not
necessarily for carson wentz i mean it
put a lot of pressure on his career and
he's not going to want that guy lurking
over his shoulder once again
right i mean that'll become a running
joke yeah hey carson i'll get you a
super bowl ring right that's what i mean
that's getting you a super bowl well
that's as soon as he has a bad game
that's what people are going to bring up
or hey don't worry the guy he'll save
you at some point something like that i
just don't think it's good for the
chemistry of the team so that's why it's
like an interesting conversation with
this foals thing because when you look
at the the teams that went to the
playoffs last year for the most part
they're pretty much set up on their
backup quarterback situation you know
you look at washington they're good you
know with heineken and fitzpatrick even
though you go well foal's in the mix
there but there's no glaring one
other than tennessee and the colts and
again we we just discussed the calls to
where i don't think that makes sense for
for them or whence
um so after that the cults really like
they really let me say this about colts
they really like where jacob eason that
would be another thing right now right
he's developing so you want him to
develop into your backup you don't
wedge nick foles exactly in front of him
also on the roster they have jaylen
morton and sam ellinger and if memory
serves and there's a chance it doesn't i
think sam ellinger
is a smart kid
who he played at texas yeah and smart
kid he wanted to emulate he wanted to
emulate you yeah right which causes me
to question his judgment seriously and
make me wonder whether he's going to be
on the 53-man roster or even on the
practice squad however big or small it
may be but uh wasn't that him
that was yes it was it was uh it was him
it was cool definitely one of those
things they show every now and then when
they're playing oklahoma but yeah
ellenger there you know i don't know if
he'll make the 53-man roster he's a
really good football player he's an
athlete we'll see but i think you know
your point about jacob eason is another
real thing if there's hopes for this guy
and he is developing and they see talent
you know again they have to decide on
you know how r wet ready he is
but either way nick foles is not the
answer no matter what i don't think you
can play that card so
you know after that it goes into the
maybe like we're talking about the young
guys do any of them need to back up some
veteran leadership the tennessee titans
like we talked about they're the ones
that jump out to me you know a lot of
these teams you really look at them you
go uh their quarterback room's pretty
set up and in a pretty good spot one
team that i will throw out there maybe
i'm wrong off the top of my brain here
because i wasn't expecting to go down
here the dallas cowboys got nothing
right i mean they got nothing behind
you know i mean we know who they got uh
uh you know some of the guys that played
last year but again they're a team
man if they were in the thick of things
and everything like that i'd be scared
to go into the year with that backup
quarterback situation maybe they'd be a
team that would look at nick foles at
some point
yeah i mean they specifically targeted
andy dalton last year to have a veteran
presence behind dak prescott and they
needed it yeah so uh that that's a
possibility as well
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports